This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The television series, Never Have I Ever, is a coming-of-age story about the ups and downs of high school. There's popular kids, unpopular kids, and drama. There are lots and lots of crushes. And of course, there's applying for college. One of the show's main characters is an overachiever. Ben is determined to get into his dream school, Columbia University. His schedule is packed with studying, extracurriculars, and tests.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。电视剧《好想做一次》讲述了一个关于高中生活起伏的成长故事。剧中有受欢迎的孩子、不受欢迎的孩子，还有各种戏剧性事件。当然，还有数不清的暗恋，以及申请大学的过程。剧中的主角之一是个追求卓越的人。本一心想考入他梦寐以求的哥伦比亚大学。他的日程表排满了学习、课外活动和考试。
Ben has no time for friends, socializing, or even breakfast. Time for breakfast, my little prince! No time, Patty. I'll just eat a jerky stick on the way. At school, Ben's time-start schedule elicits eye rolls from his classmates. I have some free time between 1.15 and 2 a.m. tonight to work on this. Are you out of your mind? We're not operating on your psycho schedule. Both of you guys just come to my house after school. I can't.
本没有时间交朋友、社交，甚至连吃早餐的时间都没有。该吃早餐了，我的小王子！没时间了，帕蒂。我路上随便吃根肉干就行。在学校里，本那精确到分钟的日程表让同学们直翻白眼。我今晚凌晨1点15分到2点之间有空闲时间来做这个。你疯了吗？我们可不会按照你那变态的日程表来。你们俩放学后直接来我家。我不行。
That's when I zoom with my Mandarin teacher. Even Ben's principal has become concerned about his constant battle with time. Your schedule is untenable. You don't even have a lunch period anymore. I don't need a lunch period. Mm-hmm. Yes, I've seen you with your meat sticks. Eventually, the stress lands Ben in the hospital. While Ben's character is exaggerated for comic effect, many people, including those who graduated high school years ago, can relate.
那时候我要和我的中文老师视频通话。就连本的校长也开始担心他与时间的持续斗争。你的日程表根本行不通。你甚至连午休时间都没有了。我不需要午休时间。嗯哼。是的，我见过你吃那些肉干的样子。最终，压力让本住进了医院。虽然本这个角色为了喜剧效果有所夸张，但许多人，包括那些多年前就高中毕业的人，都能感同身受。
Lofty goals, demanding jobs, and the pressures of parenthood leave many of us feeling burned out, on edge, and overwhelmed. This week on Hidden Brain, how the solution to not having enough time might require us to rethink our relationship with time. When we're thinking about this resource, it makes us spend more deliberately in ways that are aligned with our values,
宏大的目标、高要求的职业以及为人父母的压力，让我们许多人感到精疲力竭、焦虑不安、不堪重负。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，探讨如何解决时间不够用的问题，这可能需要我们重新思考与时间的关系。当我们思考这一资源时，它会促使我们更审慎地将其花费在符合我们价值观的事情上，
in ways that make us feel happier. Most of us live our lives in a blur. We speed through our days, rush to drop off kids, battle work deadlines, squeeze in emails before bed. Lots of us dream of doing less, much less. We fantasize about striking it rich and quitting our jobs. At UCLA, Cassie Mogilner-Holmes studies the relationship between time and wellbeing. Among other things, she has studied what happens to people who
以让我们感到更快乐的方式。我们大多数人的生活都在浑浑噩噩中度过。我们匆忙度日，赶着送孩子上学，应对工作截止日期，睡前还要挤出时间回邮件。我们许多人梦想着少做点事，少做很多事。我们幻想发大财然后辞职。在加州大学洛杉矶分校，凯西·莫吉纳-霍姆斯研究时间与幸福感之间的关系。除此以外，她还研究了那些
get their wish to have all the time in the world. Cassie Holmes, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi Shankar, thank you so much for having me. This is so exciting. Cassie, I'd like to take you back to a point in your life when you had just had a baby, your maternity leave had ended, and you were on your first work trip to New York. Can you paint me a picture of what your life felt like at the time? Yes, my life felt crazy at the time.
如愿以偿拥有了所有时间的人会发生什么。凯西·霍姆斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。你好，尚卡尔，非常感谢邀请我。这太令人兴奋了。凯西，我想带你回到你刚生完孩子、产假结束，第一次去纽约出差的那段生活。你能描述一下当时你的生活感受吗？是的，当时我的生活简直疯狂。
And so, yeah, when my son was four months old, I was invited to give a talk at Columbia's Business School up in New York, and I said yes. And it was a crazy day, but not unlike other crazy days. talk at Columbia's Business School up in New York and I said yes. And it was a crazy day, but not unlike other crazy days. It's just I remember it quite vividly. I woke up early, traveled up to New York to give my presentation, which was followed by
所以，是的，当我儿子四个月大时，我受邀去纽约的哥伦比亚商学院做演讲，我答应了。那是非常疯狂的一天，但和其他疯狂的日子没什么两样。去纽约的哥伦比亚商学院做演讲，我答应了。那是非常疯狂的一天，但和其他疯狂的日子没什么两样。我记得很清楚。我起得很早，赶往纽约进行演讲，随后是
back-to-back meetings and then sort of colleague dinner. And I rushed out of the dinner trying to make the very last train that would get me home to my son and my husband back in Philadelphia. And the cab driver, as you know, you know, New York cab drivers are already driving very fast and too fast, but I was yelling at him, which I don't tend to yell. I was like, can you please hurry up to get me to this train? I cannot miss it. And I didn't miss the train, but when I was sitting on the train that night, I remember looking out the window and as the sort of darkness was whizzing by and everyone was asleep in their homes and just like I should have been
接连不断的会议，然后是同事聚餐。我匆忙离开聚餐，试图赶上最后一班火车，好回到费城去见我的儿子和丈夫。正如你所知，纽约的出租车司机本来就开得很快，甚至太快了，但我当时在对他大喊大叫，我平时是不怎么大喊大叫的。我说，能不能请你快点，让我赶上这趟火车？我不能错过它。我没有错过火车，但那天晚上坐在火车上时，我记得看着窗外，随着黑暗飞驰而过，每个人都在家里熟睡，就像我本应该
asleep in my home and my husband and baby were asleep in our home. And I was realizing just how fast everything was going by and it was such a blur between the pressures of being an assistant professor, so you know, work. The pressure or wanting to be a good parent, a good partner, a good friend, you know, with the never-ending pile of chores that were waiting me at home, it all felt like too much. There was just simply sort of too much to do. And I remember wondering, I was like,
在家里熟睡一样，我的丈夫和孩子也在家里熟睡。我意识到一切过得有多快，在助理教授的压力——你知道，工作压力——和想要成为好父母、好伴侣、好朋友的压力之间，一切都变得模糊不清，你知道，家里还有堆积如山的家务等着我，这一切感觉太沉重了。简直有太多事情要做。我记得当时在想，
not only do I not have enough time to sort of do it all, I wasn't feeling like I could do it all well or enjoy any of it along the way. So sometime later, Cassie, you finally get to take a break. I understand you took a trip to Mexico. How did it go? Well, it was a trip to Mexico that I was so excited about because, you know, it continued to be on the heels of crazy days, of, you know, the busyness of work and getting the
我不但没有足够的时间把所有事情做好，而且我觉得自己无法把任何事情做好，也无法在过程中享受任何事情。那么后来，凯西，你终于休息了一下。我听说你去墨西哥旅行了。感觉怎么样？嗯，那次墨西哥之行我非常兴奋，因为你知道，那是在疯狂的日子、工作的忙碌以及让
kids ready and teaching and all that sort of stuff. And so I was so excited about the idea of just sitting on the beach with the book with nothing to do. And that sounded more than delightful. And it was delightful until the morning of the fourth day. And I woke up and I was like, you know, tapping on my husband's shoulder,
孩子们准备好、教学等等这些事情之后。所以我对坐在海滩上读书、无事可做这个想法感到非常兴奋。那听起来再美妙不过了。确实很美妙，直到第四天早上。我醒来时，你知道，拍了拍我丈夫的肩膀，
I'm like, all right, so what are we going to do today? I was done doing nothing, and I was eager to get going again. For many of us, this is a relatable experience. We look forward to going on vacation, only to feel bored or antsy after a few days. Just like Cassie, we are unhappy when we are busy, and we are unhappy when we have too much time on our hands.
我说，好吧，我们今天要做什么？我不想再无所事事了，我渴望重新忙碌起来。对我们许多人来说，这是一种可以产生共鸣的经历。我们期待去度假，结果几天后就感到无聊或坐立不安。就像凯西一样，我们忙碌时感到不快乐，而当手头有太多时间时，我们同样感到不快乐。
Cassie and her colleagues, Marissa Sharif and Hal Hirschfield, have studied the connection between having free time, or discretionary time as Cassie puts it, and people's happiness. What we found was interesting. The pattern of results showed an upside down U shape. So what that suggests is that on one end, people with too little time were unhappy.
凯西和她的同事玛丽莎·谢里夫以及哈尔·赫什菲尔德研究了拥有自由时间（凯西称之为“可支配时间”）与人们幸福感之间的联系。我们的发现很有趣。结果模式呈现出一个倒U型。这表明，在一端，时间太少的人感到不快乐。
So that was me on the train that night. But what was surprising to us was the other side of that arc, right? And what we found was that beyond a certain amount, there was such thing as having too much time. So when people had a whole, whole lot of discretionary hours in a day, they were also dissatisfied. So it's almost a paradox, isn were also dissatisfied. So it's almost a paradox, isn't it? Because very busy people imagine that, you know, they dream about the day they can just put up their feet and do nothing. And of course,
那正是那天晚上在火车上的我。但令我们惊讶的是弧线的另一端，对吧？我们发现，超过一定限度，就会出现“时间太多”的情况。所以当人们一天中有非常非常多的可支配时间时，他们也会感到不满。这几乎是一个悖论，不是吗？因为非常忙碌的人会想象，你知道，他们梦想着有一天可以翘起脚来什么都不做。当然，
when that day actually arrives, very quickly, like you found, you found yourself frustrated. And this is, it's apparently not just you, it's a widespread phenomenon. What explains the paradox? Yeah, and what our data suggests is that when people have too many discretionary hours in a day, they feel unproductive. And from that, it undermines their sense of purpose. And with that, people are dissatisfied.
当那一天真正到来时，很快，就像你发现的那样，你会发现自己感到沮丧。显然这不仅仅是你，这是一个普遍现象。是什么解释了这个悖论？是的，我们的数据显示，当人们一天中有太多的可支配时间时，他们会感到没有成就感。这削弱了他们的目标感。随之而来的是，人们感到不满。
You know, a few years back, there was a study in the United Kingdom that looked at the cognitive function of thousands of retirees. These were people who had held a variety of different jobs at different salary levels. And the researchers gave people a cognitive memory test 14 years before they retired,
你知道，几年前，英国有一项研究观察了数千名退休人员的认知功能。这些人曾在不同薪资水平下从事过各种不同的工作。研究人员在他们退休前14年对他们进行了认知记忆测试，
and then 14 years after they retired. Can you tell me what they found, Cassie? So what they found was that people's cognitive functioning decreased dramatically following retirement in terms of their verbal memory. And this is interesting because it suggests that when people have too much discretionary time on their hands, that it's less sort of cognitively engaging and stimulating.
然后在他们退休14年后又进行了测试。你能告诉我他们发现了什么吗，凯西？他们发现，人们退休后的认知功能在言语记忆方面显著下降。这很有趣，因为它表明当人们手头有太多可支配时间时，这种时间的认知参与度和刺激性较低。
And so what this is all pointing to, I think, is that work for many is a source of feeling engaged, feeling productive with the retiree study, it is cognitive stimulation, mental stimulation. And without that, we're not only bored, but we feel less purpose. We are less engaged and with that, less satisfied. Many of us live busy lives. We rush to work, check our email, ferry kids around.
所以我想这一切都指向一点，即对许多人来说，工作是感到投入、感到有成效的源泉；在退休人员研究中，它是认知刺激、精神刺激。没有这些，我们不仅感到无聊，而且感到目标感减弱。我们投入度降低，随之而来的是满意度也降低。我们许多人过着忙碌的生活。我们匆忙上班、查看邮件、接送孩子。
We feel our time has stretched thin and we fantasize about the day when we can finally do nothing. When that day comes, however, we often find ourselves confronting the opposite problem. We are bored, hungry for meaning and purpose. Being too idle, like being too busy, seems to make us unhappy. When we come back, Cassie's research examines how our perceptions of time influence the way we spend it.
我们感到时间被压缩了，我们幻想有一天终于可以什么都不做。然而，当那一天真正到来时，我们往往发现自己面临着相反的问题。我们感到无聊，渴望意义和目标。太闲和太忙一样，似乎都会让我们不快乐。回来后，凯西的研究将探讨我们对时间的感知如何影响我们使用时间的方式。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When most of us feel overwhelmed by life and by work, we tend to locate the problem in our circumstances. We say, I have too many deadlines tearing me in the face. I have too many commitments on my plate. I have no time. When we think about the solutions to these problems, we often resort to daydreams and fantasy. Maybe I'll win the lottery and won't have to work anymore. Maybe I could run away to a tropical island where my only responsibility is to sit under a coconut tree
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当我们大多数人感到生活和工作不堪重负时，我们倾向于把问题归咎于环境。我们说，我有太多的截止日期压得我喘不过气来。我身上有太多的承诺。我没有时间。当我们思考这些问题的解决方案时，我们往往诉诸白日梦和幻想。也许我会中彩票，就不必再工作了。也许我可以逃到一个热带岛屿，在那里我唯一的责任就是坐在椰子树下，
and sip margaritas. At UCLA, psychologist Cassie Holmes has come to believe that many people underestimate how much control they do have in making their lives less busy and stressful. A powerful moment of insight in Cassie's life occurred one day in 2017 as she was racing across campus busy and stressful. A powerful moment of insight in Cassie's life occurred one day in 2017 as she was racing across campus with a preschooler in tow.
喝着玛格丽特鸡尾酒。在加州大学洛杉矶分校，心理学家凯西·霍姆斯开始相信，许多人低估了他们在减少生活忙碌和压力方面所拥有的控制力。凯西生命中一个强有力的顿悟时刻发生在2017年的一天，当时她正带着一个学龄前儿童匆忙穿过校园。
I didn't have a long commute. I could walk through beautiful UCLA campus with my three year old to take him to preschool and me to work. And there was one morning in particular where the sun was shining. It was a spring day and the birds were chirping and my son was skipping along as happy as could be. And I was charging ahead because I was thinking about the meeting that I was going to be late to and also thinking about all the things that I had to do that day when I dropped him off.
我的通勤路程并不长。我可以带着我三岁的孩子穿过美丽的加州大学洛杉矶分校校园，送他去幼儿园，然后我去上班。那天早上阳光明媚，是个春日，鸟儿在鸣叫，我的儿子像往常一样快乐地蹦蹦跳跳。而我却在埋头赶路，因为我在想那个我要迟到的会议，还在想送他去学校后我当天要做的所有事情。
And I heard him, he's like, Mom, stop. And I was like, we don't have time to stop. Hurry up. And he's like, Mom, please stop. And I turn around and I see that his nose is buried in a bush of roses. And I without thinking, these words came out of my mouth. I was like, we don't have time to stop and smell the roses.
我听到他喊，妈妈，停下。我说，我们没时间停下。快点。他说，妈妈，请停下。我转过身，看到他的鼻子埋在一丛玫瑰花里。我不假思索地脱口而出。我说，我们没时间停下来闻玫瑰花香。
And when I heard those words, I did stop. I was like, oh my gosh. I am so in my head. I am so thinking about what's next, that I was oblivious to this perfect scene that I was in, that my son was absolutely noticing. And as a time and happiness researcher and expert, yelling into the air that we don't have time to stop and smell the roses was definitely a wake-up call. In her lab, Cassie began to ask
当我听到这些话时，我确实停下了。我想，天哪。我太沉浸在自己的思绪里了。我太专注于接下来要做什么，以至于忽略了眼前这个完美的场景，而我的儿子却完全注意到了。作为一名时间和幸福感研究专家，对着空气大喊我们没时间停下来闻玫瑰花香，绝对是一个警钟。在她的实验室里，凯西开始思考
whether she had defined the problem wrong in her own life. When she thought about being a young working mom and the many pressures on her time at work and at home, it felt really stressful. But was the problem a lack of time or the way she was thinking about time? She decided to apply the tools of science to her own life and to closely track how she was spending her days. What time tracking does is that you write down what you're doing every half hour, what's the activity you're doing, and not being so broad like, I'm at work, but in particular, what are you doing at work? What project are you working on?
她是否在自己的生活中定义错了问题。当她想到自己是一个年轻的职场妈妈，以及在工作和家庭中面临的诸多时间压力时，她感到非常焦虑。但问题是缺乏时间，还是她思考时间的方式？她决定将科学工具应用到自己的生活中，并密切追踪她是如何度过每一天的。时间追踪就是让你每半小时写下你在做什么，你正在进行的活动是什么，不要写得太笼统，比如“我在工作”，而是具体写你在工作中做什么？你在处理什么项目？
And not so broad as, oh, it's family time. What are you doing during that family time. And it's important to not just write what you're doing, but I also rate on a 10-point scale, how happy, how joyful, how satisfying I feel on having spent that time. So one can look back and have their own personalized data set that captures how they've spent their time and it allows them to pull out what are those activities that
也不要写得太笼统，比如“这是家庭时间”。你在家庭时间里做什么。重要的是不仅要写下你在做什么，我还要用10分制来评价，我在花这些时间时感到多么快乐、多么愉悦、多么满足。这样一个人可以回顾并拥有自己的个性化数据集，记录下他们是如何度过时间的，这让他们能够找出哪些活动
tend to produce the greatest amount of happiness for them, what are those activities that tend to produce the least amount of happiness for them. And in addition to that, not just the particular activities, but what are some commonalities across those happiest activities and those least happy activities? And what this also allows you to do is see just how much time you're spending across these various types of activities. Now, when Cassie talks about choosing activities that produce happiness,
往往能为他们带来最大的快乐，哪些活动往往带来最少的快乐。此外，不仅是具体的活动，这些最快乐的活动和最不快乐的活动之间有什么共同点？这还能让你看到你在这些不同类型的活动上花费了多少时间。现在，当凯西谈到选择能带来快乐的活动时，
it's not like she's saying that our only choices are to do things that make us happy or do things that make us unhappy. All of us routinely have to do things that are not fun. It's not like we can say, oh, I'm never going to clean my house or do the dishes or go to the dentist. What time tracking can show you is that you might not be allocating your time efficiently. Imagine your life was divided into different compartments. There are things that you do that are both fun and meaningful. Maybe time spent on a stimulating project at work. Then there's stuff you don't have to do but that you enjoy, like hanging out with friends or going on a vacation. A third
她并不是说我们唯一的选择就是做让我们快乐的事或做让我们不快乐的事。我们所有人都必须经常做一些无趣的事情。我们不能说，哦，我永远不会打扫房子、洗碗或去看牙医。时间追踪可以向你展示，你可能没有有效地分配你的时间。想象你的生活被分成了不同的隔间。有些事情既有趣又有意义。比如花时间在工作中的一个刺激性项目上。然后是一些你不需要做但你喜欢做的事情，比如和朋友聚会或去度假。第三
group of activities might be things you have to do even if they are not enjoyable. Chores fall into this category. But as Cassie tracked her time, she realized she was spending more time than she needed to on chores. Well there was a lot of time that I would say was wasted. And in particular, my source of wasted time is the amount of time I spend on email and responding to my inbox and trying to get through it, not just in the workday but also in the evenings. And so, and looking at my happiness ratings, I was not very happy spending my time on that particular activity.
组活动可能是你必须做的事情，即使它们并不令人愉快。家务属于这一类。但随着凯西追踪她的时间，她意识到她在做家务上花费的时间比她需要的要多。嗯，有很多时间我可以说被浪费了。特别是，我浪费时间的来源是我花在电子邮件上、回复收件箱并试图处理完它们的时间，不仅是在工作日，在晚上也是如此。所以，看看我的快乐评分，我在那项特定活动上花费时间并不怎么快乐。
What I observed in my time tracking data is that I am happiest when I'm spending time one-on-one having that good connecting conversation with the people I love, whether it is my husband at the end of the week when we have gone out to dinner away from the kitchen cleanup and are not, you know, going through the logistics of parenting in our lives and actually having the conversation that, you know, drew us to each other in the first place. When I'm hanging out with my daughter
我在时间追踪数据中观察到，当我花时间一对一地与我爱的人进行那种良好的深度交流时，我是最快乐的，无论是周末结束时我和丈夫出去吃晚餐，远离厨房清理工作，不再处理生活中育儿的琐事，而是真正进行那种当初吸引我们走到一起的对话。当我陪女儿时，
and we are chatting over a cup of coffee for me, hot chocolate for her, when I'm having a wonderful sort of enriching conversation with one of my research collaborators, walking across the beautiful UCLA's campus to get coffee or my preferred bubble tea, you know, hearing about their lives as well as talking about research. I mean, there's nothing more joyful than that.
我们一边喝咖啡（对我来说是热巧克力）一边聊天，或者当我与我的研究合作者进行那种美妙的、充实的对话，走在加州大学洛杉矶分校美丽的校园里去买咖啡或我最喜欢的珍珠奶茶时，你知道，听他们谈论生活以及讨论研究。我的意思是，没有什么比这更快乐的了。
As Cassie tracked her time like a scientist, she started to see the epiphany she'd had with her preschooler smelling the roses pointed to something much bigger. In all sorts of ways, she was not allocating her time to maximize activities that promoted happiness. She was allowing things she didn't enjoy but felt she had to do to intrude on time set aside for relaxation and rejuvenation. She noticed this acutely during a visit to Italy. We went to Tuscany, which was so wonderful, and this was one week that we were carving out
当凯西像科学家一样追踪她的时间时，她开始看到她与学龄前儿童闻玫瑰花香时的顿悟指向了更宏大的东西。在各种方面，她都没有分配时间来最大化那些促进快乐的活动。她任由那些她不喜欢但觉得必须做的事情侵占了留给放松和恢复活力的时间。她在意大利访问期间敏锐地注意到了这一点。我们去了托斯卡纳，那真是太棒了，这是我们专门留出的一周，
to not do work, to not be in that do mode, and just be on vacation. Yet I found myself in the evening looking over, you know over the Tuscan countryside, this beautiful sunset, and what was going on in my head was planning for what we were going to be doing tomorrow and coordinating that and sort of sneaking onto my phone to try to coordinate when we were going to be picked up to go, you know, to the next little town. Even worse than chores intruding on activities that promote happiness,
不工作，不处于那种“做事模式”，只是去度假。然而，我发现自己在晚上看着托斯卡纳的乡村，看着美丽的日落，脑子里想的却是计划明天要做什么，协调这些事情，偷偷用手机试图协调我们什么时候被接走去下一个小镇。比家务侵占促进快乐的活动更糟糕的是，
time tracking can show how much time you are spending on things that are neither essential nor joyful. Spending time on such activities makes absolutely no sense. One of my students I remember in particular who while working towards her degree on the nights and weekends, while working full time, she was so busy. Yet, when she looked at the data from her week, she realized that she spent a dozen hours on social media and looking at her ratings, she's like, holy cow, that is so much, particularly given how busy she is.
时间追踪可以显示你花了多少时间在既不必要也不快乐的事情上。花时间在这些活动上完全没有意义。我记得我的一名学生，她在攻读学位期间，在晚上和周末还要全职工作，她非常忙。然而，当她查看她一周的数据时，她意识到她在社交媒体上花费了十几个小时，看着她的评分，她说，天哪，这太多了，考虑到她有多忙。
And looking at the ratings that she gave, you know, it's like three and four, whereas the activities that she feels too busy that she doesn't have time to do, but gets, you know, a nine or a ten in terms of happiness, is meeting up with her sister after work for dinner. And what I think that highlights with respect to the busyness that we feel too busy to do these things that really matter to us and can really make us feel joyful, that we're too busy to do those, yet so many hours just get mindlessly filled scrolling. And it's one of those things on social media that people think, I'm just going to check.
看着她给出的评分，你知道，只有3分和4分，而那些她觉得太忙而没时间做，但在快乐程度上能打9分或10分的活动，是下班后和姐姐见面吃晚餐。我认为这突显了我们对忙碌的感受——我们觉得太忙而无法做那些真正对我们重要、真正能让我们感到快乐的事情，我们太忙而无法做那些事，然而却有那么多时间在无意识的滚动屏幕中被填满了。这是社交媒体上人们常做的事情，人们想，我只是看一眼。
It'll just be a couple of minutes. But inevitably, a couple of minutes turns into tens of minutes. But then those tens of minutes over the course of days sum up to hours and hours. And for those of us who feel so time poor, this is important to recognize because it suggests where can we reallocate some of our time so that we can spend more on moments of joy.
只会花几分钟。但不可避免地，几分钟变成了几十分钟。然后这些几十分钟在几天的时间里累积成了数小时。对于我们这些感到时间匮乏的人来说，认识到这一点很重要，因为它暗示了我们可以重新分配一些时间，以便在快乐的时刻上花费更多。
Cassie also noticed that when she was not mindful about how she spent her time, she would start to multitask. Even when she was doing things that she needed to do and loved to do, her mind would be somewhere else. One time, Cassie noticed herself doing this as she was listening to a scientific presentation on the risks of distraction. It was just so sort of on the nose. As a professor, one of the joys of our work is that we get to go to research seminars where other faculty will come and share the research that we're working on. And it's joyful because we get to learn what is happening in science. And there was this fascinating presentation where the researcher was sharing the dangers of being distracted on cell phones among drivers.
凯西还注意到，当她不注意自己如何度过时间时，她会开始多任务处理。即使她在做她需要做且喜欢做的事情时，她的心思也会在别处。有一次，凯西注意到自己在听一场关于分心风险的科学报告时就这样做了。这真是太贴切了。作为一名教授，我们工作的乐趣之一就是可以参加研究研讨会，其他教员会来分享他们正在研究的研究成果。这很令人愉快，因为我们可以了解科学界正在发生什么。当时有一场引人入胜的报告，研究人员分享了司机在手机上分心的危险。
So being distracted on the cell phone while driving is more deadly, more dangerous than even driving inebriated or drunk. And while he was telling us about the dangers of being distracted on our phones, I was distracted. And on my phone, you know, I was nodding, trying to pretend that I was listening, but instead I was on Amazon going through my to-do list of ordering a gift and wrapping paper for my son to go to a birthday party that week and emailing the team, his soccer team, about, you know, who's going to bring the snacks. So I was being pulled out of this experience that could have been really enriching and illuminating
所以，开车时在手机上分心比酒后驾车更致命、更危险。当他告诉我们手机分心的危险时，我却分心了。我在手机上，你知道，我点着头，试图假装我在听，但实际上我正在亚马逊上查看我的待办事项清单，为我儿子那周要去参加的生日派对订购礼物和包装纸，并给他的足球队发邮件，关于谁来带零食。所以我被从这个本可以非常充实和有启发性的体验中拉了出来，
because I was distracted by my to-do list. The less mindful we are about how we deploy our time, the more we feel stressed out and over-scheduled. This has implications not just for our personal happiness, but how we behave toward others and how others behave toward us. A famous study in the 1970s demonstrated this. It centered around a parable from the Bible, the good Samaritan who stops to help another person in distress. This is a really interesting study and conducted among the kindest individuals one could come
因为我被我的待办事项清单分心了。我们对如何部署时间越不留心，就越感到压力和日程过满。这不仅对我们的个人幸福有影响，还影响我们对待他人的方式以及他人对待我们的方式。20世纪70年代的一项著名研究证明了这一点。它围绕着圣经中的一个寓言，即停下来帮助另一个处于困境中的人的“好撒玛利亚人”。这是一项非常有趣的研究，是在最善良的人群中进行的，
across, seminary students. And their task was to present the story of the Good Samaritan to others in a room that was down the hall. On their way out, some of the participants were told that they were late, that they didn't have a lot of time. And on their way, there was actually a man on the side who was coughing clearly in need of help. Unbeknownst to the participants, he was someone who was hired as a confederate for the study.
神学院的学生。他们的任务是向走廊尽头房间里的其他人介绍好撒玛利亚人的故事。在他们出发的路上，一些参与者被告知他们迟到了，他们没有多少时间。在路上，确实有一个人在旁边咳嗽，显然需要帮助。参与者不知道的是，他是被雇来作为研究同伙的人。
But what the researchers were looking at is whether someone who was told that they were late, who felt like they were in a hurry, would be likely to stop and help. And indeed, they found when people felt they had scarce time, they were less likely to stop and help someone. I understand that you've conducted a study and found a similar effect.
但研究人员观察的是，一个被告知迟到、感觉自己很匆忙的人，是否会停下来提供帮助。确实，他们发现当人们感到时间紧迫时，他们停下来帮助他人的可能性就越小。我听说你进行了一项研究，也发现了类似的效果。
Is that correct, Cassie? Yeah. Well, I conducted a study among college students simply leading them to think about how busy or not that they are. And I had them write a paragraph about how busy and how many things they have to do that day versus a control condition where they just wrote about their day.
是这样吗，凯西？是的。嗯，我在大学生中进行了一项研究，只是引导他们思考自己有多忙。我让他们写一段关于他们那天有多忙、有多少事情要做的话，而对照组则只是写关于他们的一天。
And then I asked them whether they would be willing to stay an extra 15 minutes to help out a high schooler by editing their college application essay. And what I found was simply thinking about one's busyness made people less likely to be willing to spend the time to help another. So we've looked at lots of ways that the feeling of time scarcity can change our attitudes toward others, change our behavior.
然后我问他们是否愿意多留15分钟，通过编辑高中生的大学申请论文来帮助他们。我发现仅仅是思考自己的忙碌程度就使人们不太愿意花时间去帮助他人。所以我们研究了许多时间匮乏感如何改变我们对他人的态度、改变我们的行为的方式。
One thing we haven't discussed is how time scarcity in some ways is a trap. It sets us up to make choices that will likely increase our time scarcity in the future. Psychologists describe something called the yes-damn effect. What is this, Cassie? Yeah, this is an important study to remember. Gal Zoberman and John Lynch, what they did was they asked people to think about today and all that they have to do today and the busyness of the day.
我们还没有讨论的一点是，时间匮乏在某种程度上是一个陷阱。它让我们做出很可能会增加未来时间匮乏的选择。心理学家描述了一种叫做“是的，该死”效应（Yes-damn effect）的东西。这是什么，凯西？是的，这是一个需要记住的重要研究。加尔·佐伯曼和约翰·林奇，他们所做的是要求人们思考今天以及今天必须做的所有事情和忙碌程度。
And they also asked them to think about that same day of the month, one month from now. And inevitably, people thought that they will have more time available one month from now than they do today. But that's absolutely not true because what thinking that you'll have more time available one month from now does is that when you are asked to do things, you say yes. You're like, sure, I will bring the snacks to that event in a month because I, you know, like while I'm busy today, I will surely have more time than, yes, I will, you know,
他们还要求他们思考一个月后的同一天。不可避免地，人们认为一个月后他们会有比今天更多的空闲时间。但这绝对不是真的，因为认为一个月后会有更多空闲时间，会导致当别人要求你做事情时，你会说“好”。你会说，当然，我会带零食去参加那个活动，因为虽然我今天很忙，但我一个月后肯定会有更多时间，是的，我会，你知道，
give a talk for that conference because I will have more time then, but of course there's no way I have time, would have time to do that today. And by thinking, having this bias that we think we will have more time available in the future, that we will be less busy in the future than we are today.
为那个会议做演讲，因为那时我会有更多时间，但当然我不可能有时间在今天做这件事。通过这种偏见，我们认为未来会有更多时间，认为未来会比今天不那么忙。
We take on these commitments that when the day comes, that we've said yes, and then when the day comes, we say damn, hence the yes-damn effect. You know, several years ago, I was interviewing Eldar Shafir at Princeton University, and I was telling him how busy I was, how stressed out I was, and he said, let me give you a rule. If someone suggests you do something two months from now, you should ask yourself, can I do that thing today? If it was today,
我们承担了这些承诺，当那一天到来时，我们已经说了“好”，然后当那一天到来时，我们说“该死”，这就是“是的，该死”效应。你知道，几年前，我采访普林斯顿大学的埃尔达·沙菲尔时，我告诉他我有多忙，压力有多大，他说，让我给你一个规则。如果有人建议你两个月后做某事，你应该问自己，我今天能做那件事吗？如果是今天，
would I be able to do it? And if the answer to that question is no, you should say no to the thing that's two months from now because presumably you're not going to be any less busy two months from now. So I said, okay, that's a great rule. I started calling it the Eldar rule. But then I asked Eldar, how often do you follow the Eldar rule? And he said, I never follow it. So it's one thing, Cassie, to know that the bias exists. It's another thing to actually do something about it.
我能做到吗？如果那个问题的答案是“不”，你应该对两个月后的那件事说“不”，因为大概两个月后你也不会比现在更不忙。所以我说，好的，这是一个很棒的规则。我开始称它为“埃尔达规则”。但我问埃尔达，你多久遵循一次埃尔达规则？他说，我从来不遵循。所以，凯西，知道这种偏见存在是一回事，真正采取行动是另一回事。
Yeah, and I would actually sort of put it through a different filter, which it's not only how busy do you think you are today versus will be then, is that tasks something or that requests something that you want to do today. That it seems worthwhile, because it's very easy to say yes to things when you're like, oh sure, later, because you don't value your time quite so much in the future. But using a sort of purpose filter or a happiness filter of
是的，我实际上会通过一个不同的过滤器来过滤它，不仅仅是你认为今天比那时有多忙，而是那个任务或请求是否是你今天想做的事情。它看起来是否值得，因为当你觉得“哦，当然，以后再说”时，很容易对事情说“好”，因为你并没有那么看重未来的时间。但使用一种目标过滤器或快乐过滤器，即
if I were asked to do this today, would I say no, not just because I'm too busy, but because it's something that I don't want to do and doesn't feel worth my time. Mm-hmm, so in other words, we not only discount how busy we're going to be in the future, in some ways we discount the happiness of our future selves by saying, yes, this is not really particularly enjoyable, but I'll just pass that off and my future self will take care of it.
如果我今天被要求做这件事，我会拒绝吗？不仅仅是因为我太忙，而是因为这是我不想做的事情，而且觉得不值得我花时间。嗯哼，所以换句话说，我们不仅低估了未来会有多忙，在某种程度上，我们通过说“好”来折损了未来自己的幸福，这并不是特别令人愉快，但我只是把它推开，未来的我会处理它的。
Exactly. When we come back, how to recalibrate your relationship with your time. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Most of us think about time the same way we think about money. We have a limited supply of it, and life would be better if we only had more. At UCLA, Cassie Holmes has discovered a number of paradoxes in the way we think about time. First, people who have too little to do are often as unhappy as people who have too much.
正是如此。回来后，如何重新校准你与时间的关系。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们大多数人思考时间的方式和思考金钱的方式一样。我们拥有的供应是有限的，如果我们有更多，生活会更好。在加州大学洛杉矶分校，凯西·霍姆斯发现了我们思考时间方式中的许多悖论。首先，事情太少的人往往和事情太多的人一样不快乐。
Second, when we feel we have no time, it changes our behavior. It makes us focus less on others. It keeps us from enjoying wonderful things around us. It prompts us to make decisions that more or less guarantee we will be overstretched and exhausted in the future. In her book, Happier Hour, Cassie suggests there is a radically different way to think about time. Cassie, you once asked volunteers to think differently about their weekends right before the weekend started. What were your instructions to them and what did you find?
第二，当我们觉得没有时间时，它会改变我们的行为。它使我们减少对他人的关注。它阻止我们享受周围美好的事物。它促使我们做出或多或少保证我们在未来会过度劳累和精疲力竭的决定。在她的书《更快乐的一小时》中，凯西建议有一种截然不同的思考时间的方式。凯西，你曾经要求志愿者在周末开始前以不同的方式思考他们的周末。你给他们的指示是什么，你发现了什么？
Yes, among a sample of working adults leading into the weekend, we randomly assigned some to treat that weekend like a vacation. And the others, we told them to treat that weekend like a regular weekend. What did you find? We followed up with them on Monday when they returned to work to measure how happy they
是的，在周末前的一组职场成年人样本中，我们随机分配了一些人把那个周末当作假期来对待。而其他人，我们告诉他们把那个周末当作普通的周末来对待。你发现了什么？我们在周一他们回到工作岗位时对他们进行了回访，以衡量他们有多快乐。
are. And what we found was that those who were simply instructed to treat their weekend like a vacation were happier on Monday when they were back at work and they had enjoyed the weekend more. And we were interested in what drove this. Did people spend their time differently? And we did find that people, there were slight differences in how people spent their time.
我们发现，那些仅仅被指示把周末当作假期来对待的人，在周一回到工作岗位时更快乐，而且他们更享受那个周末。我们对是什么驱动了这一点很感兴趣。人们花时间的方式不同吗？我们确实发现人们在花时间的方式上存在细微差异。
So those who treated the weekend like a vacation did spend a little bit less time doing housework. They spent longer eating, so sitting at the dinner table. They spent a little bit more time in bed with their partner. So these are things that are, you know, activities that are like being on vacation. What was interesting too, was that what the activities that they did over the weekend actually didn't significantly
所以那些把周末当作假期来对待的人确实花在做家务上的时间少了一点。他们吃饭的时间更长，也就是坐在餐桌旁的时间。他们在床上和伴侣在一起的时间多了一点。所以这些是，你知道，像度假一样的活动。有趣的是，他们周末所做的活动实际上并没有显著
influence how they felt when they returned to work on Monday. What did drive that change in happiness was their mindset. So those who were treating the weekend like a vacation were more engaged in the activities they were doing. They were more in the present, which allowed them to enjoy that time more and which then, having enjoyed their weekend more, being fully engaged, not being distracted by, you know, like all of the work or all of the chores that are looming over, you know, waiting for us, it allowed them to be happier when they returned to work on Monday. You know, I've often noticed when I travel overseas or to a new city somewhere, you know, you're taking in
影响他们周一回到工作岗位时的感受。驱动这种幸福感变化的是他们的心态。所以那些把周末当作假期来对待的人更投入于他们正在做的活动。他们更多地活在当下，这使他们能够更享受那段时间，而享受了周末，完全投入其中，没有被那些悬而未决的、等待着我们的工作或家务所分心，这使他们在周一回到工作岗位时更快乐。你知道，我经常注意到当我出国旅行或去某个新城市时，你知道，你在吸收
everything and you're absorbing everything and your eyes are wide open, but if we look at the people who are the locals, you know, they're often hurrying around getting to work, bored with their commutes, and they're seeing the same city that you're seeing, but of course your experience of it is completely different. And similarly when you're in your home city and you see tourists, you know, the tourists are standing around taking pictures of buildings that you walk by every day and you've never stopped to look at the building, let alone take a picture of it.
一切，你在吸收一切，你的眼睛睁得大大的，但如果我们看看当地人，你知道，他们经常匆忙赶去上班，对通勤感到厌烦，他们看到的城市和你看到的一样，但当然你对它的体验是完全不同的。同样，当你在你居住的城市看到游客时，你知道，游客们站在那里给那些你每天经过的建筑拍照，而你从来没有停下来看过那座建筑，更不用说给它拍照了。
And in some ways that's speaking to exactly the idea that you're talking about, Cassie. There's something about being a tourist in our own lives that in some ways opens us up and makes us pay attention and be mindful of what's happening around us. Absolutely. And the thing that we're subject to in the routine of our lives is that we get used to it. Our tendency to hedonically adapt, it's called hedonic adaptation, that is, after repeated exposure, we stop noticing it as much. And this is good that we adapt when bad things happen because it makes us resilient, but it's not so good in the face of, you know, joys in our life because we don't notice them as much.
在某种程度上，这正是你所谈论的观点，凯西。在某种程度上，作为自己生活中的游客，会让我们敞开心扉，让我们关注并留意周围发生的事情。绝对是这样。我们在生活常规中受到的影响是，我们习惯了它。我们享乐适应的倾向，这被称为享乐适应，也就是说，在反复接触后，我们就不那么注意它了。当我们适应坏事发生时，这是好事，因为它让我们有韧性，但在面对生活中的快乐时，这就不那么好了，因为我们没有那么注意它们。
You know, if you think about the first time your partner said, I love you, you know, your heart is bursting with happiness. And then 10 years on in a marriage, I love you, it has been shortened to love you as a way to sort of say goodbye in the morning, and you don't even hear the words. So there is something that when things happen every day, they feel every day and we don't notice,
你知道，如果你想想你的伴侣第一次说“我爱你”的时候，你知道，你的心充满了幸福。然后结婚10年后，“我爱你”被缩短为“爱你”，作为早上告别的一种方式，你甚至听不到这些话。所以当事情每天发生时，它们感觉很平常，我们没有注意到，
and we're missing out on the potential joy from those pleasures that are right there in our daily experience. Cassie started to ask, are there other techniques to get people to change their relationship to time? In one study, she gave volunteers a set of tasks and asked some of them to think about time and some of them to think about money. What I found was that those who were led to think about time compared to a control condition and a money condition actually planned to engage in activities that were happier activities so involving social connection or those activities that made them feel fulfillment. Whereas when people were led to think about money,
我们错过了那些就在我们日常体验中的快乐所带来的潜在喜悦。凯西开始问，还有其他技巧能让人改变与时间的关系吗？在一项研究中，她给志愿者一套任务，要求一些人思考时间，一些人思考金钱。我发现，与对照组和金钱组相比，那些被引导思考时间的人实际上计划从事更快乐的活动，即涉及社会联系或那些让他们感到满足的活动。而当人们被引导思考金钱时，
it actually led them to plan to spend more time doing work. In other words, one way to change the way you spend your time is to simply ask yourself how you are spending your time. Cassie has found that once people are put into a state of mind where they are thinking about time, their behavior changes too. In my work, I didn't just want to see how people plan to spend their time. I also wanted to see how thinking about time versus money would influence people's actual behavior. So I went to a coffee shop as a place where people are socially
这实际上导致他们计划花更多时间工作。换句话说，改变你使用时间方式的一种方法是简单地问自己你是如何使用时间的。凯西发现，一旦人们进入思考时间的思维状态，他们的行为也会改变。在我的工作中，我不仅想看人们计划如何使用时间。我还想看思考时间与金钱如何影响人们的实际行为。所以我去了咖啡馆，作为一个人们社交的地方
connecting and spending time with others, which is an activity that's associated with greater happiness. And people also are on their laptops working. On the way into the cafe, I asked them to complete a survey, which surreptitiously exposed them to time-related words or money-related words. And then, unbeknownst to the participants, we watched how they spent their time in the cafe. And what we found was that those who were led to think about time spent a greater proportion of their time at the cafe connecting with others.
与他人建立联系并共度时光，这是一种与更高幸福感相关的活动。人们也会在笔记本电脑上工作。在进入咖啡馆的路上，我请他们完成了一项调查，调查中暗中让他们接触了与时间相关的词汇或与金钱相关的词汇。然后，在参与者不知情的情况下，我们观察了他们在咖啡馆里是如何度过时间的。我们发现，那些被引导去思考时间的人，在咖啡馆里与他人交流的时间比例更高。
So chatting with others in line, talking to others in the space, versus those who are actually led to think about money, spend a greater proportion of their time working. And so I think what this research shows is that thinking about our time, being more thoughtful and intentional about this resource that is our life, right, how we spend our minutes add up to our hours or years or decades in our life overall. And when we're thinking about this resource, it makes us spend more deliberately
也就是说，与排队时的人聊天，与空间里的其他人交谈，而那些被引导去思考金钱的人，则将更大比例的时间花在工作上。所以我认为这项研究表明，思考我们的时间，对我们生命中这一资源更加深思熟虑和有意识，对吧？我们如何度过每一分钟，最终累积成我们生命中的小时、年或几十年。当我们思考这一资源时，它会让我们更审慎地去花费它。
in ways that are aligned with our values, in ways that make us feel happier. I understand that you've sometimes had volunteers happier. I understand that you've sometimes had volunteers do a rather unusual exercise, which is to write their own eulogies. Why would you ask them to do this, Cassie? What writing your eulogy does is it leads you to think, take that broader perspective of your time, thinking about your life as a whole. So it is how at the end of your life do you want to be
以符合我们价值观的方式，以让我们感到更快乐的方式。我明白你有时会让志愿者做一些相当不寻常的练习，那就是写下他们自己的悼词。你为什么要让他们这样做呢，凯西？写悼词的作用是引导你去思考，从更广阔的角度看待你的时间，思考你作为一个整体的人生。所以，在生命结束时，你希望自己如何被
remembered? What legacy do you want to leave? And by articulating that, writing out a eulogy that you would hope that will be presented about you, what it clarifies is, is what are those aspects of you that are really important? What are those words that you hope people use to describe you? What are your values? And by thinking about that, what life do you want to live, that can inform how you spend your hours today. Another technique along the same lines is called the times left exercise. So if you reflect back on your past week and identify what was a moment of joy, oftentimes it's a very ordinary experience. And so what I encourage people to do is count how many times have you done that in your life so far, and then to count how many times do you have left to
记住？你希望留下什么样的遗产？通过表达出来，写下一份你希望别人为你宣读的悼词，它能让你明确：你身上哪些方面是真正重要的？你希望人们用哪些词来描述你？你的价值观是什么？通过思考这些，你想要过什么样的生活，这可以为你今天如何度过时间提供参考。另一个类似的技巧被称为“剩余时间练习”。如果你回顾过去的一周，找出哪一刻是快乐的，通常那是非常平凡的经历。所以我鼓励人们做的是，计算一下你在生活中已经做过多少次这样的事，然后计算一下你余生中还剩下多少次
do it in your life. An example here is I have my students do this. And one of my students, who is in her late 20s getting her MBA, counted her dinners with her parents. And what she calculated, thinking about from her childhood, other than the study in summer that she was studying abroad in high school, and then counting once she went off to college, visits home, and then when she was living on the other side of the country for work, when her parents would come out to visit,
可以做这件事。这里有一个例子，我让我的学生做这个练习。我的一位学生，20多岁正在读MBA，她计算了她与父母共进晚餐的次数。她从童年开始计算，除了高中时在国外学习的那个夏天，然后计算她上大学后回家探亲的次数，以及后来她为了工作搬到国家另一边居住时，父母来看望她的次数，
and then she moved back to California to actually be closer to her parents, and they had Sunday night dinners. And she counted all of those up and realized that she had had about 6,800 dinners with her parents thus far in her life. And then in calculating how many dinners does she likely have left, she counted that she had about 575 dinners left.
然后她搬回加州，为了离父母更近，他们开始一起吃周日晚餐。她把所有这些都加起来，意识到到目前为止，她一生中已经和父母共进了大约6800次晚餐。而在计算她可能还剩下多少次晚餐时，她算出大约还剩下575次。
That is, she had only 8% of her dinners with her parents left. That is, she had only 8% of her dinners with her parents left. And that's impactful because what it does is it leads her to A, make the time, no matter how busy she feels, with that recognition, she is going to show up for the Sunday night dinner. But even beyond that, at the dinners, it changes how she engages in that time. You know, like her mom's, what she used to view as nagging comments, she would just let roll off her shoulders. And instead, she, you know, redirected the conversation to learn about her parents, recognizing that their time together is limited and more consequently is really precious. And so wanting to make the most of it. You know, it's so interesting that I think once something is in the past, it's easy to recognize how precious it was. I mean when you think about
也就是说，她与父母共进晚餐的次数只剩下8%了。也就是说，她与父母共进晚餐的次数只剩下8%了。这很有冲击力，因为它促使她：A，无论她觉得有多忙，只要意识到这一点，她都会去参加周日晚餐。不仅如此，在晚餐时，它改变了她在那段时间里的投入方式。你知道，比如她妈妈以前被她视为唠叨的评论，她现在只会一笑置之。相反，她把谈话引向了解她的父母，认识到他们在一起的时间是有限的，因此是非常宝贵的。所以她想充分利用这段时间。你知道，这很有趣，我认为一旦事情成为过去，就很容易认识到它有多么宝贵。我的意思是，当你想到
the walks you had with your son when he was going to preschool across the UCLA campus when you were too busy to smell the roses, you can look back on that now and realize it was really precious. But at the time, you were like, how do I get through this walk really quickly so I can drop him off to get to work? There's a real irony there, isn't it? Which is when we look back, we can actually see how precious things are. But when we look in the present, we often fail to notice that things in fact are precious and are finite.
你儿子上学前在加州大学洛杉矶分校校园里和你一起散步的时候，那时你太忙了，没空去闻花香，现在回想起来，你会意识到那真的很宝贵。但在当时，你会想：我怎么能快点走完这段路，好把他送去学校然后去上班？这真是一个讽刺，不是吗？当我们回顾过去时，我们实际上能看到事情有多么宝贵。但当我们审视现在时，我们往往没有注意到事情其实是宝贵的，而且是有限的。
Yeah, and that's why it's so important to recognize their preciousness before we've passed them by so that we don't end up feeling regret. Cassie has also found another powerful way to help people achieve a healthier relationship with time. Seek out moments of transcendence. Awe is the state where your perspective expands well beyond yourself. When we feel our time is scarce, we behave in very limiting ways that we pull into ourselves,
是的，这就是为什么在它们流逝之前认识到它们的宝贵性如此重要，这样我们才不会最终感到后悔。凯西还发现了另一种帮助人们与时间建立更健康关系的有力方法。寻找超越的时刻。敬畏是一种让你的视角远远超越自我的状态。当我们觉得时间匮乏时，我们的行为会变得非常局限，我们会退缩到自己的世界里，
that we don't think about, we don't have confidence that we can complete all that we sort of want to and ideally would like to do. Whereas by shifting our perspective, expanding our perspective, then it also expands our sense of how much time that we have. Not all of us, of course, can hang out at the Grand Canyon with mouths agape. Most of us are not astronauts who get to see the earth from outer space. But Cassie argues that there is a simple way for each of us to get out of our own head. Exercises this activity that unfortunately we often don't do when we feel that we don't have a lot of time.
我们不去思考，我们没有信心能完成所有我们想做且理想中愿意做的事情。然而，通过转换视角，扩展我们的视角，它也扩展了我们对拥有多少时间的感知。当然，并不是我们所有人都能在大峡谷前张大嘴巴惊叹。我们大多数人不是宇航员，无法从外太空看到地球。但凯西认为，我们每个人都有一个简单的方法可以跳出自己的思维定式。锻炼就是这样一种活动，不幸的是，当我们觉得没有太多时间时，我们往往不做。
I often ask people to complete the sentence, I don't have time to blank. And exercise is often one of those things that people don't feel they have time to do. And that is not good because exercise, research has shown that exercise is wonderful. It increases our cognitive functioning. It increases our self-esteem. So making us feel like we can accomplish what we set out to do. And it's a mood booster. It makes us feel happier in our subsequent activities. How we experience the limiting nature of time when we feel that time is scarce.
我经常让人们完成这个句子：“我没有时间去……”。锻炼往往是人们觉得没时间做的事情之一。这不好，因为研究表明锻炼非常棒。它能提高我们的认知功能。它能提高我们的自尊心。让我们觉得我们可以完成我们设定的目标。而且它能提升情绪。它让我们在随后的活动中感到更快乐。当我们感到时间匮乏时，我们是如何体验时间的局限性的。
We don't feel like we have enough time to complete what we set out to do. But by exercising, through increasing our sense of self-efficacy, it actually expands our sense of what we can complete within our given time. And I am absolutely subject to this. When I don't feel like I have time, my early morning run is the thing that I sacrifice because I'm like, oh, I need to get ready for the day.
我们觉得没有足够的时间去完成我们设定的目标。但通过锻炼，通过增强我们的自我效能感，它实际上扩展了我们在给定时间内可以完成的事情的感知。我绝对会受到这种影响。当我感觉没时间时，清晨的跑步是我牺牲的事情，因为我会想，哦，我需要为这一天做准备。
I need to catch up on email. But in those moments or at those times where I do make the time out on that run, as the sun is rising and I am in flow, I all of a sudden don't feel constrained. In fact, I sort of approach the day, I come back, you know, running up the steps, ready for the day, nicer to those around us. We talked about how being time-poor makes us stingier with her time with respect to others. And so it is a very expanding activity.
我需要回复电子邮件。但在那些我确实抽出时间去跑步的时刻，当太阳升起，我进入心流状态时，我突然不再感到受限。事实上，我以某种方式迎接新的一天，我跑上台阶回来，为新的一天做好准备，对周围的人也更友善。我们谈到过时间贫困如何使我们在对待他人时变得吝啬。所以这是一种非常具有扩展性的活动。
Well, so many of these ideas really speak to the notion that when we are in some ways thinking expansively about our time as opposed to in this very you know I'm stressed out I'm burned out I don't have time when we have when we don't have this you know the walls are closing in mentality in some ways almost it opens up the possibilities of what we can do with our time. Does it seem that way to you Cassie? Yes it opens up the possibilities of what we can do with our time. Does it seem that way to you, Cassie? Yeah. So it opens up the possibilities of what we can do with our time. It also makes us think about our time from a broader perspective, from a bird's eye view,
嗯，这么多想法确实说明了一个概念，即当我们以某种方式对时间进行扩展性思考，而不是处于那种“我很压力，我精疲力竭，我没时间”的状态时，当我们没有这种“四面楚歌”的心态时，在某种程度上，它几乎打开了我们利用时间可能性的空间。对你来说是这样吗，凯西？是的，它打开了我们利用时间可能性的空间。对你来说是这样吗，凯西？是的。所以它打开了我们利用时间可能性的空间。它也让我们从更广阔的角度，从鸟瞰的角度来思考我们的时间，
where we're thinking more about our years and less hour by hour. And with that broader perspective, then it's more these questions of what do I value in life? And that influences how we, where we spend our time, spending more on things that are important, rather than just urgent. rather than just urgent. In some ways, Cassie, so much of this work has been about the idea that we miss the forest for the trees when it comes to time.
我们更多地思考我们的岁月，而不是逐小时地思考。有了这种更广阔的视角，那么更多的问题就是：我在生活中重视什么？这会影响我们如何、在哪里花费我们的时间，更多地花在重要的事情上，而不是仅仅花在紧急的事情上。在某种程度上，凯西，这项工作很大程度上是关于这样一个观点：当谈到时间时，我们只见树木，不见森林。
And in many ways, when we step back and look at the big picture of time, it changes our relationship to time in really profound ways. I'm wondering whether you've taken this insight to heart yourself. How has this changed the way you lead your own life? I absolutely, it influences both how I spend my time spending on activities that are, no matter how busy I feel
在许多方面，当我们退后一步，审视时间的全局时，它以非常深刻的方式改变了我们与时间的关系。我想知道你是否已经将这种洞察力铭记在心。这如何改变了你自己的生活方式？我绝对做到了，它影响了我花费时间的方式，无论我感觉有多忙，我都会把时间花在
on those activities that are truly important to me, that connect me with the people I love, that allow me to engage with work that does feel purposeful. But I would say even more than the types of activities that I engage with, it's really how I approach that time. And it's not even so much about how much time you spend, it's really how engaged, how not distracted I am so that
那些对我真正重要的事情上，那些让我与我爱的人建立联系的事情上，那些让我能够从事确实有意义的工作的事情上。但我会说，比起我参与的活动类型，更重要的是我如何对待那段时间。这甚至不是关于你花多少时间，而是关于我有多投入，有多不分心，这样
I'm not missing out. An example that is so precious to me is my morning coffee dates with my daughter. Once a week, my daughter Lita and I go to a coffee shop. And this started actually as a very routine functional activity where after dropping off her big brother's carpool on the way into dropping her at her preschool, which is next to my office, we would stop for coffee because I needed caffeine and she was just tagging along. But what was routine, we turned it into this special tradition. And during that half hour, we would sit and delight in each other's company.
我就不会错过。一个对我来说非常宝贵的例子是我和女儿的早晨咖啡约会。每周一次，我和女儿莉塔会去一家咖啡店。这最初实际上是一个非常常规的功能性活动，在送完她哥哥的拼车，顺路送她去幼儿园（就在我办公室旁边）之后，我们会停下来喝咖啡，因为我需要咖啡因，而她只是跟着。但我们把常规变成了这个特殊的传统。在那半小时里，我们会坐下来，享受彼此的陪伴。
I would drink my coffee, she would drink her hot chocolate, we would munch on croissants and we would just be together. And it was 30 minutes, you know, in the week, but that 30 minutes when, you know, you asked me how happy I am in life, I am absolutely happy.
我会喝我的咖啡，她会喝她的热巧克力，我们会吃羊角面包，我们只是在一起。那是一周里的30分钟，你知道，当你问我生活中有多快乐时，我绝对是快乐的。
Cause that 30 minutes is time that I look forward to, that we look forward to. So we anticipate while spending it, we're happy. And reflecting back, we remember it as this and we think about it as this source of true connection. And I feel I have a wonderful relationship with my daughter that from this 30 minutes it is it colors my week and really the joy that I feel in my life overall. Cassie Holmes is a social psychologist at UCLA. She's the author of Happier Hour, How to Beat Distraction, Expand Your Time,
因为那30分钟是我期待的时间，是我们共同期待的时间。所以我们在花费它时充满期待，我们感到快乐。回想起来，我们把它记作这种真正的联系源泉。我觉得我和女儿有着美妙的关系，这30分钟给我的周生活增添了色彩，也确实是我生活中整体快乐的来源。凯西·霍姆斯是加州大学洛杉矶分校的社会心理学家。她是《更快乐的一小时：如何战胜分心，扩展你的时间，》的作者，
and Focus on what matters most. Cassie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week, we continue our U2.0 series with a look at how to say one of the smallest but most significant of words, no.
并专注于最重要的事情。凯西，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢。 “隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。下周，我们将继续我们的“U2.0”系列，探讨如何说出最简短但最重要的词之一：不。
I walk into the house laden with groceries and I see her husband sitting in the backyard kicking back with a beer. And there was something about that experience that just made me mad. If you know someone who would enjoy today's episode or any of the episodes in our U2.0 series, please show them how they can listen to the show on their favorite podcast platform or on our website hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我提着杂货走进屋子，看到她丈夫坐在后院喝着啤酒放松。那种经历中有些东西让我感到生气。如果你认识的人会喜欢今天的节目或我们“U2.0”系列中的任何一集，请告诉他们如何在他们最喜欢的播客平台或我们的网站hiddenbrain.org上收听该节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。